jetzt haben wir den ich würde sagen ich
springe auf denen drauf und dann instant
weiter auf den nächsten und da ist das
ding sehr schön wie noch nie heraus
ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute jump
league und wir haben wieder eine
zuschauer challenge um staaten diese ist
der absolute oberkirch habe die bereits
ausprobiert ich bin zweimal kläglich
gescheitert das ist die folgende hinten
kommentar leider nicht mehr dem change
vorgeschlagen wurde deswegen an den
kommentarschreiber du weißt dass die
change von dir ist schreib doch mal die
kommentare wie dein name war dann gebe
ich dir die erwähnung im nächsten video
auf jeden fall city challenge vor dass
wir die t shirts challenged ich malen sg
gemacht haben rückwärts machen
damals habe ich für jeden kill ein t
shirt angezogen in der heutigen folge
werden wir für jedes jump blick modul 1
ausziehen das heißt aber
notwendigerweise dass wir am anfang
11 t shirts anziehen müssen um pro modul
1 ausziehen zu können zehn module macht
sinn zweck und am ende noch als
anzuhaben
also plus 111 stück insgesamt epages
mega mega tricky wenn ich spiele dann ab
das ist ein krasses gefühl da kann ich
nicht mehr konzentrieren aber ich will
das machen ich mir gefällt die ideen des
wegen patmos nicht schlips setzt dann
habe ich elf t shirts an und wir sind in
der doppelrunde 321 so würde ich aus den
leute für jeden tag zu mcdonald's und
nicht mehr trainieren gehen würde
schaut mal mit safe t shirts an so eine
tiefe lagen stoff lage ist das gibt mir
ist gerade aufgefallen dass ich bei den
letzten zwei versuchen ein t shirt zu
viel an hatte also 12 statt 11 das mache
ich jetzt sagt er natürlich nicht
leichter aber ich bin gespannt und wir
packen
achja ich sollte vielleicht noch
hinzufügen dass meine haare
selbstverständlich tolles zerstört sein
werden bezieher jetzt schon sind diesmal
elf t shirts hintereinander an dann geht
jede frisur zu grunde jede frisur
ruiniert dabei aber scheiß drauf heute
sich im frisuren halt geht es darum dass
sie mit elf teams spielen und das beste
rausholen
ja okay der trick ist natürlich immer
welchem lud abschließend muss ich dann
halt einmal die koffer herausziehen und
ein t shirt wegschmeißen und ein
kopfhörer wieder rein das kostet mich
relativ viel zeit selbstverständlich bin
mir nicht sicher was wir leisten können
aber ein bisschen was wird gehen
deswegen ghoga
nur eins ist
weg gut fühlt sich ganz gut an so ist
die stimme weg zu setzen meine frisur
wird dadurch immer bilder als auch mega
schwierig sich dann so konzentrieren
ehrlich gesagt so wie man sich so ein
t-shirt vom kopf weist bei dem nächsten
moment wieder hellwach in champéry zu
sein und ja keine fehler zu machen nicht
so easy glaube ich okay nächster versuch
existiert zwei t shirts weg 9 haben wir
doch alle ok und es passt wir sind auch
relativ gut platziert werden glaube ich
über platz eins mit wir sind mhw
jetzt gerade auf platz eins aber ich
sage euch heute ist es so mega schwer
sich da zu konzentrieren
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt ob es
daran liegt dass man einfach 11 würden
bis jetzt noch neunter sun-hardware dass
das ein mega warm ist und was man sich
mehr gefühl aber es ist sehr schwierig
sich zu konzentrieren aber ich versuche
mein bestes
ich nehme ich nehme doch ernst leute
seht schon heute ist mir alles egal
heute ist mir egal wie ich aussehen der
face kempe ist egal wie ich kommentiere
ich will einfach nur möglichst weit
kommen bei dieser challenge und dann
natürlich am ende versuchen im dm mit
schönen kleinen rauszuholen aber
momentan sieht's gut aus ihr streit mit
dem anderen platz eins und das nächste
weg wir haben jetzt weg das modul 5
heißt vier tische sind runter auf 7 t
shirts und es fühlt sich immer besser an
muss ich sagen je leichter ich werde
desto besser für lecce ich hier durch
das jump'n'run natürlich bildlich
gesprochen aber ich mein ich werde auch
in wirklichkeit leichter also ein t
shirt weg jetzt nicht die welt aber 11 t
shirts kommen wahrscheinlich auch
zusammen auch schon ganz ordentliches
gewicht aber wir entledigen uns dieses
gewichts jetzt mehr und mehr haben ist
das ein bisschen zu kurz
mein name gewisse routine bei den
modulen schon also man weiß dann wo man
wie springen muss
jetzt hats aber sehr schön dass auch
einmal richtig knapp und das nächste t
shirt beck volleyball alle gebäude von
meiner mutter
sorry mama die hat noch mal extra meine
t shirts gewaschen gebügelt hitze knödel
jetzt hier für diese challenge machen
was mache ich hier eigentlich im leben
aber momentan ist es mir das wert mehr
um zehn prozentpunkte vorsprung auf den
hinter uns wissen mhw 59 der wirte
andere ist aufgewühlt glaube ich okay
aber es sieht gut aus die frage ist wie
werden die hard modeln aussehen weiß man
nicht so aber das nächste tief gewürfelt
den knopf habe ich jetzt doch nicht
abgerissen hat die kurzform gefühlt ist
es so wild gerade ok konzentrieren und
habe das ding bei deinem text
nächster jackpot und das nächste stück
flöten
ich glaube dass das größte problem weil
die größten schwierigkeiten der change
ist echt die konzentration es ist auch
schwierig zu konzentrieren wenn sich das
umfeld so krass fand das ist eine
veränderung des umfelds um auf einmal
weniger an hat und es ist ungefähr so
als würde man werde den job league
aufnahme möglich 20 kilo abnehmen oder
so dass es komplett krass das nächste
tief geflogen so damit sind wir jetzt
weil modul 98 t shirts heimischen
abgeworfen und das sind alles module
gehe ich eigentlich ganz gut leiden kann
und das haben wir auch direkt geschafft
ins sehr schön also jetzt flutscht es
wirklich perfekter moment der muss man
sagen der nächste check point und noch
ein tipp was viel entsorgen können jetzt
haben wir nur 2 anja semesters facto ja
gutes habe ich nicht aufgepasst so das
modul meine ich ist auch machbar ich
weiß nicht ob ich schon mal eine
verfehle starb
ist relativ neu aber es sollte gehen ok
passt so weit dann ist hier erst mal die
gastgeber mit und jetzt stehen wir kurz
vorm finish nein als ob ich da sie kurz
pip das ist so die ärgerlichen sprünge
wenn man einfach meinte sprung ist sie
also da muss man wirklich nicht
verpacken sechseinhalb stunden später
jetzt haben wir würde sagen ich springe
auf denen drauf und dann instant weiter
auf den nächsten und da ist das ding
sehr schön heraus dass zensieren und
sind jetzt bei einem t shirt mit dem wir
auch angefangen haben und sorglos
kräften gerade was was was das spannend
ist aber wir haben unsere rüstung wir
haben also voll nacht rhythmus punkte
und es sieht gut aus
leute es sieht gut aus nach menge
aufnahmefähig ziemlich nerven gekostet
haben sieht es echt gut aus wir machen
hier schon mal den ersten kehl kommt
geht auch nicht als gutachter der die
zwei frei zu bekommen
aber dafür haben wir richtig gut aus
wenn er ist wieder weg sehr schön farm
ein bisschen food unten rein jump links
allerdings tut die ganze meute der
anklage sind immer noch wie man extrem
auch nerven verlieren kann weil die
leute richtig krass abstauben macht aber
jeder so oder weil die leute zum
beispiel alle auf denen gehen da die dir
gut hat es auch nicht selten und wenn
die leute wissen dass es ein youtube in
der runde ist dann hat man sowieso
verloren
dann geht es noch aber jetzt mache ganz
ohne kers hier gefällt mir ja okay da
geht der erste mal dauert immer noch
fehlen aber sticker bisschen früher
nachkommt weiß was gold nämlich auch
noch mit dass wir hier noch pfeile auch
wichtig also wie kann man mitnehmen
ich glaube die anzahl der items aus der
kiste nehmen kann hängt von der
berechtigung zur herausnahme von items
von dem typen abwehr getötet hat also
wenn der denn jemanden tötet
beispielsweise drei teams aus der küster
nehmen darf weil er kein abbild gekauft
habt dann darf jeder andere denn an
diese kiste geht auch nur drei
herausnehmen auch wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel sechs herausnehmen darf ein
entsprechendes update gekauft habe für
meine
so kombiniert oder ihr komme ich schon
was die hinten drin ist so pam pam pam
pam okay gut alles klar aber leute es
hat sich gelohnt man die ersten zwei
aufnahmen versuche waren so anstrengend
aber jetzt flutscht ist kam schon baby
mach nicht so was hat er sie einmal zu
schnell umgedreht aber hat auch nach
hamm eine sehr bewusste hat auch die im
7 rüstungs punkt habe ich aber noch
einen mehr orientieren ein bisschen
locker und unterwegs sehr schönem pass
von safe okay ein gutes seht ihr ein
update es gesehen notiert sie ja wohl
schon sagen ja wir tolle alte mit der
angel oder wie als wir das wird das
übelste weise den münchner ich mir jetzt
kommt noch einer von unten wieder
oder man hat einen schönen lage unter
freunden aber jetzt an eis direkt rein
er ist direkt vor meiner bringt nichts
sieht gut aus wir haben auch gefühlt
eine ganze menge kills gemacht würde ich
sagen ich will schon sagen zweistellig
so können wir hier bist ein kessel so ja
du kommst du nie mehr raus du bist jetzt
der und zack und der ist weg so sie fall
kommt der andere hat andy war wenn auch
ein kräftiger wir können auch einen mega
wie kräften personal hier zeigt nämlich
noch mal flott acht teile aber jetzt 16
pfeile
wir haben die acht rüstungs punkt wir
haben stein schwert dass das ding ist
eigentlich das einzige was ich mir
vorstelle könntest es dass er sich jetzt
wieder verstecken will aber jetzt immer
ziemlich nah dran dass sie gut aus und
wir geben förster der turner klappt
nicht wo al qassimi böse kommen wo alter
das ist richtig gut ist jetzt weg und er
hat nur noch ein leben
und dann gehört die runde uns leute
hinein gegen mons noch immer nicht
überspringen oder ist alles klarer
vorteil ein
der kommt nicht raus ist gestoppt und
das war's das für ihn das war's für ihn
wir unseren letzten kiel die windows ce
es sehr schön bar
so muss es laufen dann fürs zuschauen
wenn ihr weitere change ideen habt rein
damit in die kommentare das war es von
mir bis zum nächsten mal